Welcome everybody to another holistic health hour. We got a bunch of questions. Yeah, there's so much things to go over
so let's get started here. Oh, you know what I put that down at the bottom. I wanted to go over this announce
But it's just so you know that there'll be no
Zoom call on Monday, January 4th. I have to be traveling that day. So
I apologize, so we won't have that first
Wednesday in
January
2023 so
Those that are listening to this act of that time means nothing to
Those were listening live, you know
That's true. So here's a question chronic yeast infections chronic Candida infections
Four years of constant infection and nothing seems to help burning pain sometimes a little itchy
By last test with the clinic still showed yeast infections don't supplement antibiotics
Supplements antibiotics and diet in this yeast infection is still there. Not sure what direction to go from there
That's really difficult chronic yeast infections are really difficult
the
The new
Course that we're going to have on holistic health and healing
It's going to have some information on more on specifically on chronic yeast infections
But it's still it's a very difficult thing to deal with so whenever you know you don't want to make light of that and
You already know that it's hard
But when practitioners just say oh, yeah, you're just going to take this probiotic and things are going to get better
It's just not that easy
There's some things that you can think about doing
Um with chronic yeast infections that um, I will type out here
One can be doing probiotic
Uh, animals
So probiotic animals can be held
So that's where you mix probiotics into just a warm water solution
And then you do an animal using an animal bag with the probiotic
Um, you try to hold it as long as you possibly can
um
And that's a probably you can look up how to do a probiotic animal there's different
Instructions on it, but you're basically doing it just like a coffee animal that you're using a probiotic water solution instead
Another thing that you can do is make a paste out of
um
Played yogurt
plus um
probiotics
So well yogurt have probiotics in them, but not very much so you're adding probiotics
Like a capsule open up a capsule of probiotics to a half a container of yogurt
You don't need a lot of yogurt mix it up and let it sit on the counter at room temperature for about 30 minutes
And then you actually have to take that in the shower and put that up your forefaces
Um, everywhere you can you can gargle with it you can eat it that way
So if you add probiotics to you yogurt to eat that's beneficial. Why eat yogurt all the time
It's not helping. Well, there's not really truly a lot of pro living culture in yogurt. So you want to add that to that um
So that's one thing to do you could actually do an animal with that as well
That's another possibility
So when you add probiotics to yogurt and leave it sit for a half an hour
It's going to kind of liquefy more because as the probiotics are growing in there
It will kind of break down the yogurt called the yogurt um milk
Cultures it'll it'll become much more liquid um and you can then use that as a animal too
um
So did you get into more serious thing is to try to deal with your gut issues and that has to do with um doing um
You know
Sebo protocols and um different gut protocols and healy gut protocols um and then even was called a fecal transplant
So fecal transplants really gross
But that's where you're taking
Um uh feces from a healthy person so somebody who does not have yeast infections
This is a really gross, but then you blend it up and you basically do an animal with that feces
Why that's horrible while there's so much living culture in that other person's feces
That it can be beneficial to help grow new culture in your gut
Um nobody wants to hear about that. That's actually a fantastic treatment for colitis ulcerative colitis
Inplanetary bold is bowel disease and it can be good for just horrible chronic yeast infections as well
Certainly want to start with some of the other ideas first
Can you talk about the fads genes and what the circle or genitis three and minus two mean
So your fads genes are you know it's right there um on your
Um your genetic summary master what they have to do
It really has to do with your ability to digest and utilize fat production
I'm not going to read this to you
But I think what this person is talking about is on your genetic summary
There's a minus three or a minus two or a minus one or a minus zero or a plus one or plus two or a plus three
What does that mean
That means
How far off a variant of normal are you now? There's about 50,000 people
That have put their genetics into this software
So
Obviously other clinics other than us on of that 50,000 people
Where do you lie as far as being
You know how bad are these genes you could say it that way how bad are you with the fads genes or any genes
Um
Compared to the 50,000 people if you're in the minus if you're a might if you're at zero you're
Equally the same as everybody else that here's a graph that you can't see on your chart
But here's a graph. This is actually of your fads genes
So if you're plus three you're way over here. This is you
This is the mean. This is the average of those 50,000 people
That means this is better
You're way better than the 50,000 people so if you are showing a minus side
On any of those genes that means you're better than the
Mead of that population if you're showing a positive
Three and you're really a lot worse than the average population
So far that you go away from the mead is a cup is is the number
So if you are a plus one here's an example of
Somebody who is a negative two on something. So you're far on the left side of the mead
This is the a different gene. This is the FUT2 gene
Flora the left side of the mead mead. This is something that you may want to address your FUT2 genes have to do with gut function and gut healing
So this might be something you want to address
Certainly with this if you're this you don't need to do anything with your fads genes. You're doing great
But here this is a plus two I think you are at you know
Much worse than you're worse than the normal if you want to say that mead is the normal
That is the normal of the population of the people that are in this
software
So that's what the plus means plus means you're actually on the negative side. It's just how
um
Statistics are read and might as means you're on the you're on the good side
So if you have a might if you're at zero
Might as one plus one. Yeah, not really too much to worry about whether you're at
Well, you're at
Plus two plus three. That's something you might want to address
Uh, vasculitis. I think they mean I have remember I'm just copying pasting your your questions from right how you type
So because cognizant of that when you're typing out your questions
The vasculitis discoloration on my fingers. I eat a clean diet plant based occasionally organic chicken and salmon
The supplements I was taking contained glycerin could this sugar alcohol cause the inflammation in my blood vessels
Um, certainly a can um anything can be a cause of that um, it is um
You know
That's just one possible thing glycerin in your supplements. Maybe
Oh, remember there's a small amount of glycerin in your supplements. I far
Think that um
That you have as a better chance that it is a some sort of food sensitivity
Um to something something that you're eating so you could eat a perfectly clean diet and you could still have antibodies to different foods
Uh, so if you have antibodies to foods. It's really the protein
in the foods um, and it's really um
the um
peptide so I'll break down of that protein
Uh, in that food. So let's say use gluten for example gluten is a very long protein
called gliaden and gliaden breaks down in your stomach and
By the hydrochloric acid and ultimately by the enzymes created by your pancreas um to different peptides down to just different amino acids
So it's not gonna be much more likely that you have a sensitivity to foods
And the way that you would find that out is you would run a syrex test
So a syrex 10
So that would be that's called the array 10 um
Uh, would be the most appropriate tests for that that tests life 300 different foods or something like that
And that will test the peptides of the cooked and raw
This is the best way to do it because the peptides are different if the food is cooked versus raw
That's how you'd find that out
Besides an anti-inflammatory diet eliminate supplements that contain glycerin
What detox method can I incorporate what supplements do suggest
So again going back to this i'd say more likely at some sort of food you might want to do if you don't want to run an array 10
Because i don't know if they're 500 bucks or something like that you could do a food elimination diet
So you could cut out different foods
And then see if things change and then re-incorporate different foods. So you could google
How do you do a food elimination diet to find a food sensitivity
There's um lots of information on that
By December 8th blood test results indicate my iron is
Uh, and ferritin is normal. So your iron and ferritin are normal, but your hemoglobin is low
So um
Most likely your iron is at the lower and and then normal for your hemoglobin to be low your ferritin could be normal
Um or even elevate and have low hemoglobin because ferritin is a function of iron
Carrying capacity, but it is also a function of inflammation in your body
Also
This person states their lymphocytes are low. How can I increase hemoglobin and lymphocytes?
Well, you have to determine what if you have low hemoglobin you have some sort of anemia
so um
It could be still iron deficiency anemia
Um, it could be B12 or prodigious anemia
Uh, it could be fallic um
acid anemia
So there's different types of anemia that you'd have to determine what that is
So providing a functional practitioner locally would be the best thing to do. I can't really do that over zoom
Um, I am gonna soon have a bunch of videos on
On interpreting blood work that will be helpful, but I don't have no something
By D B12 is over 2000. So let's say if a person's B12 this is the same person is over 2000. Can we rule out B12
Anemia? Well, you're really still clear
So you could have a B12 anemia because you can't absorb B12
Um, and then your B12 would be low
You could have a B12 anemia because you're not getting B12 into the cells
And then your B12 would be high for average
I would not stop taking B12 just because my B12 is high in my blood
So I would continue on the B12 um, if your B12 is higher than blood
That actually could indicate that it's not getting into the cells very well
So you need to keep it higher than blood. So I would not stop that would be 12
There's no harm at having an elevated B12 in the blood. So I would keep reading that
My electrolytes results are normal. Why am I thirsty during the night sometimes?
Well, there's lots of reasons why you can be thirsty during the night
You can still be dehydrated. It can still have normal electrolytes. So
Um, it's not a direct one-on-one relationship there. So um
Uh
So you so I'd still make sure you're too breaking when you're thirsty
How do I find out if I'm TH1 or TH2 dominated?
Do I need to get tested by who and where do I go? So
First of all, you have to find out if you have an autoimmune disease or what stage of that autoimmune disease you are
There's three stages of autoimmune disease
um
But uh in order to find out if you have antibodies to self tissue
You really have to go to do a syrax test again. So syrax is a lamp. So that's the name of a lab
Um, and they are specialists in running antibody testing
So syrax labs is
What labs that you would get
You could order them
Through our site or any functional medicine doctor that knows anything would be running syrax labs
This particular one that I show with diagrams up here is the syrax array 14
Which is the mucosal immune reaction
Test
It tests a bunch of antibodies for different um
tissues and different things in your body
Just to give a general picture overview
Uh, there's this person have autoimmune disease. You could certainly run a standard
Like lab core test and test for different antibodies, but like a and a
antibodies and um, you know, there's different things that you could test for lab core through your doctor as well
Um, so you want to see if you have antibodies to self tissue
Skyroid test to see if you have antibodies to the thyroid TPO antibodies things like that
How do you know if your th- what are th- two dominant where you could vary between th- what are th- two dominant
Dominates and the best way to really know that is just clinically so there's not really a test for that
I mean you can run cytokine panels
But those can change day-to-day too, so that really wouldn't be the test this perfect test for that
So in a th- one dominance your body is releasing a greater amount of different types of chemicals called cytokines
Then you are at a th- two dominance
One of the best ways to do that is just from a clinical standpoint is
If you are autoimmune and you take immune supplements does that make you feel better or worse
Many of those people
Because their th- one dominant um, th- one side of the immune system is the immune killer side th- two side is more the B cell
Make an antibody side
So if you're if you're already th- one dominant and you do things to stimulate your immune
Process that you'll actually feel worse
So if I take vitamin C doesn't make me feel worse
Yeah, it really does. Well, then you're probably th- one dominant
You really should not be taking supplements that are immune
Stereolensitive you can find a list of those in my bulk health. I might kill you
If you're th- two dominant same thing so you just you know do taking green t extract and curcumin boy
That makes me feel a lot worse and I feel better when I take
Vitamin C that you're probably th- two dominant and you shouldn't be taking things that stimulate the th- two side
Here's a really a test for that which you should be testing for antibodies and if you have an autoimmune disease
That's what you should be looking for
Also, since we're no longer doing cheek swab testing. How do I know if I still have mold or Candida issues?
There's a lab through great print plates laboratory called the micotoxic profile. It's a really good lab
That shows mold and the different types of mold that a person could have in their body
So that's a great test to run
um, and that will change over time
So as you treat that one mold
Um, then you know, you could run the test again and you could see the change
You would see that in people time of time again. So that's a test that you could run
um
You could really know a lot by your symptoms too. If you know you have a history of mold or Candida problems
You still have symptoms probably could still pretty good chances still there
So it's not always a need to do expensive testing. So you have to use your
You know your deductive reasoning sense and put on your Sherlock Holmes hat a little bit and go okay
Well, this is still going on and kind of dig to how you can better your situation
Also, my husband bought a spooky to write machine. I'm wondering if I could use that to detox the mold and Candida
I'm not a specialist in spooky two or not a fan of spooky two
But certainly it can be a tool that could be beneficial. So contact spooky two
See if they have programming for mold and Candida certainly you have a tool. You should use it
so
I live in the country on 10 acres and over 20 years. I picked out hundreds of ticks on me
Could uh should I be tested if I don't if I'm lying. I'm so aware
Yeah, that's a good thing
Remember the deer tick is a little bit different than your regular ticks or you like that
You know, you could take ticks off you all every day. It's still made out good line
But run it to me the best test is the DNA connections test. I talk about the different tests on the line
Course that I have
I don't know if you're in the line course or not
But it's on the testing page
You're not in the line course then certainly you could just order the DNA connections test
It's a test that you do at home. It's in urine test
So it's super easy to do you can order it through our store
Again, none of these tests are real cheap though. It's the problem
There's um, they can be expensive
But then all you get is the positive or negative moment nice thing about the DNA connections test is a test for
Like 11 or 13 cold infections as well
And it gives you this is either highlighted or it's not highlighted. It's a super easy to read
We just email you the results you just it's just so easy to look at and read some of the other
More complicated and much more expensive tests are really difficult to understand
How to interpret them
So I like the DNA connections tests. It's real simple. You can do it at home. So look into that
All right, remember
Those who call January 4th, that's the first Wednesday of next month
I will be traveling so we'll be able to do that. So
Thank you all
So I'll be praying for you and um continue with your great questions
Bye-bye